you did something that i say is almost
impossible to do you posted a a song of
yours i don't know which song it even
was was a white iverson or what what did
you post on soundcloud why not white
iverson yes all right you write this
song and you don't have a record deal
you're just another schlub living at
home yes sir
and you post it on soundcloud
and how soon do people start listening
to this song like instantly and like did
you play this for anyone or you just put
it right on soundcloud so i moved to la
with my good friend jason and he is such
a beautiful [ __ ] man and he gave me
jason gave me [ __ ] everything how old
were you let me
i was 18. yeah you graduated high school
yes sir i remember driving out there was
a studio in the palisades and
out here in the uh palisades
and um i remember saying hey jason man
can i take the car out like can i please
take your car to go stay at the studio
and so we would go and stay at the
studio and i remember cutting that
record because i made the beat and i
remember staying at his house and
and i was like this beat is [ __ ]
crazy and so i just sat there by myself
like very much so like i did when i was
when i was a teenager just sat there and
i was like
this [ __ ] is good i like this [ __ ] it is
good
to hear it's good for me and so um we
went
um and i'm and i met a buddy and we
stayed out in the palisades and recorded
the record
and um
the night it was done i was like let's
just [ __ ] put it up what's the worst
that could happen how weird is it that
like all of a sudden kids started
passing this thing around
to the point that you were getting like
a million streams in a month
like it was i mean you're an unknown guy
i think that um it very much had to do
he's an atlanta guy named fat man key
and he is the most beautiful man in the
[ __ ] world and he was there at the
studio whenever i dropped it so and he
was he was buddies with wiz and what
does batman key do you put it up on
tweeted it he tweeted it he or he sent
it to wiz and then it just went [ __ ]
nuts and then like all these guys waka
flocka like everything like
uh people i [ __ ] looked up to for so
long were just like
facetiming me in the middle of the night
and i was like yo what the f like this
it's crazy